one of the things that we have to
remember and I think young people don't
realize this is when someone gives you a
shot when they decide to put you on a
stage and give you a microphone or if
they give you a job or if they um open a
door for you or make an introduction for
you you don't have to prove yourself
because you've already been vetted
somebody else has already said I you see
this in new employees all the time you
the the company Chanel like Chanel they
have this rule that I absolutely love
that new new senior executive
are not allowed to speak in meetings for
the first 90 days of their
employment they want you to shut up and
listen and the reason they do that is
because new employees so often feel they
have to talk in every meeting to prove
that you made the right choice to hire
them like we know you're smart we hired
you